I really want to start with a sincere
thank you I love these movies and I know
how much effort it takes to make these
movies and I just really want to thank
you for everything for you and Chad for
making these oh thanks man I appreciate
that
um you have done this movie has again
insane action set pieces and you've done
them in all four movies what where do
you rank like some of the sequences like
what do you think is like the top three
in terms of the difficulty and
everything that went on behind the
scenes to pull them off are we talking
about just chapter four no I'm talking
about all four movies what do you think
oh my gosh yeah what do you what do you
think uh well I'm just curious like were
you ranking like the difficulty in
certain sequences uh uh let's see uh the
first one that comes to mind was the
horse sequence in chapter three
um I would say just as the First Time
The Assault sequence in chapter one I
would say the dance party fight in
chapter two and I would say probably
it's a tie between the Arc de Triomphe
car sequence and this stair sequence
it's acrocur so one of the things that
blew me my eye my jaw was on the ground
in chapter four with the sequence in the
Berlin Club because you have all these
extras behind you during the sequence
dancing it's to the lights yeah it's
it's crazy because for people that don't
realize when when you think about an
action scenes there's never other
there's not a lot of extras because the
choreography of what it takes so can you
sort of explain to people why that
sequence is so so hard to pull off yeah
it's a nice detail uh
well you're dealing with space and also
you're dealing on the strength of the
people who are in the background in the
sense of committing to it like they had
to like
keep dancing or be in the moment and
kind of just ignore that fight scene
that's going on around you and in front
of you uh so that kind of cooperation uh
keeping the kind of moment alive and
feeling authentic
uh so it's really just
practice run throughs people getting
used to the action around them and
actually Chad uh had gone professional
dancers
and seated them throughout the
background so there was people who knew
their bodies and movement and spatial
relationships and so these kind of PODS
kind of I think made this
tertiary kind of connective
kind of world that I could weave and
Scott Atkinson I could weave through as
well as the other stun performers yeah
by the way Scott disappears in that suit
it's yeah it's crazy it's amazing yeah I
I couldn't believe it like everything
about that sequence is fantastic
um I have one minute left with you so I
want to ask about a few other things if
you don't mind real quick you told me a
little while ago that you were thinking
about directing Berserker uh I don't
know the script just came in it's at
Netflix waiting for notes we'll see what
happens Constantine two as you know
we've spoken about Constantine at least
a few times yes cannot believe that a
sequel might actually happen what's the
status
um DC World
reevaluating whether or not they want to
do a Constantine with me in the movie so
fingers crossed I I understand because
it's because there's a lot of changes
going on I'm hoping it could be like an
elsewhere else world's title you know
where it just exists yes so do I
my last thing for you what are you
actually filming this year I have no
idea oh you want like you you really are
just I'm I'm looking for work I will
pass it on to many people all right
thank you sir thank you so much for your
time and seriously congrats on this
movie